beheadings massacres of civilians ethnic
cleansing the Islamic state groups shock
and horror approach to establishing
their Caliphate in large parts of Iraq
and Syria has got many asking for a
full-on United States attack but there's
one looming question if it wasn't for
the war on terror waged in response to
the 9/11 attacks by al Qaeda would the
Islamic state group even exist at all
probably not after 9/11 two countries
Afghanistan and Iraq were invaded and
the costs were high what went wrong
well here are just a few of the
consequences of the war on terror us-led
military campaigns have directly claimed
the lives of more than 300,000 civilians
in Iraq Afghanistan and Pakistan alone
more than 6,800 US soldiers were killed
waging these wars indirectly the
civilian death toll could be well over a
million when we consider the devastating
effects on neighboring countries and the
conflicts spawned by the war on terror
and then they are the refugees Iraq
alone has more than 1.4 million refugees
and more than 1.3 million internally
displaced people some of them triply
displaced let me explain some left their
homes during the us-led invasion and
crossed into Syria then they fled back
to Iraq when the Syrian civil war began
and are now fleeing their homes once
more as the Islamic state group
continues to gain ground in Iraq and
that brings us to the creation of armed
groups it may have started with al Qaeda
but over the years al Qaeda splintered
into many factions with various agendas
groups such as Boko Haram in Nigeria
Russia Bob in Somalia and the Islamic
state group to name a few and even
though US President Barack Obama said in
2013 that the global war on terror is
over
this war like all wars has been one
Sodom obey is still open
US drone strikes continue to kill
civilians on foreign soil and the United
States continues to pour money into what
it deems anti-terror operations and how
much does all of this cost
well since 2001 the United
States has spent four point four
trillion dollars on this war for a war
that seems to have no end in sight or is
the point of it all to have no end
so who loses out perhaps it's all of us
imagine the schools that could have been
built the diseases that could have been
cured the poverty we could have tackled
or are there too many people benefiting
from the war on terror to end it tell us
what you think subscribe on YouTube
follow us on Twitter and like us on
Facebook